ん
この某所なんですけども越冬脳波センサーが入ってます
で脳波センサーを測定することによってといえばあの僕はすごい興奮するとですね
校風もすごいあのこんな感じであの
すごい入ってしまいます例えばり安置するとグリーの様々なコーデて
がコアのやってしますそして
なんか青いさまざまこれは眠い時でます
で全部5ですねこうあのでるんですけども本当は今日檀家の皆様に全部これをですね
あのう
つけてもらってですねあれば僕の話がすごいつまらなかったらもうみんなお医者もだと
かほぼ合ってるみたいな感じでちょっと考えたんです
ところが a と電磁つ僕脳波センサーを測定しましたらなんと
常にですねぼく5分興奮状態みたいで会おうツーサポーターってました
なので急遽マニュアル目
シャボン玉をですねだしたいとかをしました
はい
でなので
例えば僕はもうたまに言葉つとなるんですけどまぁするやったらこんな感じで幸福の方
あたらが真っ白ってところですね伝えたいと思ってます
はいじゃあへとちなみにこの帽子は昨日様の作ったんですけど
観光ヒーローですねこのようにコアをくりぬいて作りました
なんかのこんな感じでも使うことで8
こんな帽子が出来ました
で
本を超えと今回今日ですね皆さんお伝えしたい事に入っちゃいます
えっと休養シティアイディアそしてクリエーションです
で今日はこの3つについてちょっと話してみたいと思います
で皆様はどう中学校高校時代って何をされてましたか
えっと例えばまあ皆さん部活とか結構いられたと思うんですけども
8僕はですねなんと自分の部屋になんかこんな感じで
えっとだかよくわからないですよねなんかあの配電盤なんですこれをつくりまして
家じゅうの天一をコントロールしました
ちょっと夫婦だやんないと思うんですけども高い一車スラに行ってました
で極めつけはこの後ろになるですねぷろぺらんです
これがいったん全開で回るとですね
家の空気が約7分で全部入れ替わるっていう
なんかちょっと考えづらいことが起きました
ただ当時ていか
無駄かということは僕まだ知る由もありませんでした
ただのすごいもう作るのが好きで作ってました
でまぁそんな事はてたんで僕もあの
3浪しました山楼しまして
浪人したんですけどもまぁ当然僕勉強そっちのけでですね
だからもうこんなノートとか作ったりとかしてこうアイディア午後ゆかんだな効能とを
変えてますあっになんか色んな子は僕宇宙が好きだったのでなんか宇宙みたいなことを
書いたりとかですね
よしましてまあやっとですね
大学に受かることができましたでそこで僕はあの
書き続けたノートですね部屋であの方
なんか実現したいと思いまして実現したのがこれです
これは叩くもアパートなんですけど宇宙船を作ります
でねこれただの抽選ではなくて家15燃料棒での管理します
んですか大戦略をコアを色々作ったりとかですね
高いせましたで桐光学園のスキャンでなんかこう
アパートなんですが爆音がもう4が聞こえてしまうので
ロスね雨量計あのガラケーフィーチャーフォンであの
エアコンコントロールさ
とかあるいは玄関ドアとかですね今後あげたりとかもしてました
であとはまあほど例えば極めつけはですね
8太陽光発電へ並行インターフェースを作ることでなんといえどですね
だいたい250 w 位の太陽光パネルを張り巡らしまして
その結果ほとんどまあ基本料
金850円ぐらいでまぁ3年間過ごせました
なんか結構もう僕まあこれも結構好きななんというかな
あの楽しい気持ちだけで作ったんですけどですけどもまぁ当然二の単位に苦労し事は
言うまでもありません
でまぁそんなこんなでやっと工部大学校を卒業したんですけども
あのなんかん
土地論者として僕大学院ありましたそこで興味を持ったのはあのプロジェクション
マッピングした
で結構いえば凄くプロジェクションマッピング流行ってるんですけど僕が注目したのは
煙です
煙とかシャボン玉とかそういう好不安定なものに対してプロジェクションすると何か
こうワクワクすんじゃないかと思いまして僕はこんな機会を作ったんです
これ何かっていうとあのサボン玉フェイキーです
でこれあの煙ようですねボワーってを出すと
ボコって5分できましてこれに対して何かこう
プロ辞書んしようって思ったんですねでそこでまぁ特殊なカメラを使ってですね
シャボン玉を取ることであっ落っこちてきたらまあ意味
依存すると例えば当時3位はボートプレゼントが落ちてきたら
なんか一緒にこうしていくとかあるいはこうシャボン玉生まれたらメリークリスマス
みたいな感じで紅陵ができたらいいですね
あとはまあ怪我の匂いをつけることでバラの花は領土シャボン玉を交ダンスこともあの
しました
こんな感じであの作ってみたんですけど実はこのバージョン土がこの帽子なんですね
a これ何を血迷ったか脳波フェイスをつけてしまったんで
けれども日本で結構す感情豊かな国で例えば
花火とかお花見とかってこう一瞬のものにこう思いをはせるっていうかあって
で風に伝えることをなんかシャボン玉ってオブラートにこのせてー何が新しい
コミュニケーションできたらなんかワクワクしてるんじゃないかと思ってこれを作り
ました
ただボクは常に興奮状態だったみたいですよね
me
入ってえっとまぁ今ですねでこんな感じで僕じゃあなにやってるのかって言いますと
あの実は
色々とハードウェアをつくってきたんですけども六甲もう究極のハードやっていったら
やっぱり
タンパク質ですタンパク質と
結構今議会とかって多いんですけど多分
将来的いうと dena からタンパク数行フェイしてそれをコアの自衛隊に行こう
機械都市銀が語を使っていくみたいな世界を僕は
年ってますそこで注目したのは4役です
薬ですねってあの今何やってるかって言うとこんな感じですね
越冬 dna を自動的にあのコアの生成することで例えばあの交換妻を今作ってい
ます
で
いろんなこの機械学習とか人工知能とかですね
あとロボティックスとか by を組み合わせることでしまったそういうも爆速であの
薬が作る者になっています
それを最大限利用してこういうロボット今字一から作りましていま
取り組んでいますただえっとこういうロボットって
やっぱり本当に言うともう
いっぱいそうなんですね音すごく今っても多いいっぱい台数が必要で
で小鹿を実現するために僕は何か今考えているのですね
こんな感じであの600形みたいなロボット今作っていますこれを例えば8ソースの
要因ですね
こう並べることでそれぞれのロボット化実験をします
でそうするとゆっくり
ここはですね困るであのなんとかジャイアント構図会みたいな感じで
無数にロボット並べてそれはのんなんとかな
あのそれぞれ加工薬を作ることでまあトラック
てればいいと言うカバークロス4役を開く速度加速度的に幸を行いたいって言うにょ回
思い描いて日々取り組んでおります
はい
でなんか今日すごいお伝えしたい言葉ですでなんかコアのやっぱり僕ってこうやっが
アイデアクって結構でひらめいたら
やっぱりクリエーションをしていかないとこの世界に現れないと思っていたので
まあ僕ってこうなんだろうな呼吸するように行こう
この作りたいと思ってやってきましたで
ただそのアイデアってじゃあどうやってくるのとか
なんか相手が重い次いだどうやって思い作ってこうあのなんかを考えてみたんですけど
やはり
号考えてみたところ給料シティだと思います
で
あのなんというかまぁかの有名なあの
ん
実にもですねバーンとアイディアがその9陽性と言ってましてボックスの同意なんです
けどもやっぱりその窮状すって言って煌1フォルドでなくいろんな価値観がすごいある
と思ってまして
すごいいろんな休止があると思いますってちょっと日は僕なんて例えばこんな感じで
間取りですね
なんかプロペラつけたりとか
あとなんかこうプロペラいっぱい買ってきてベッドに並べて寝るとかって
僕にとってそういう給料してというか
あのちょっと理解できないと思うんですけどファンなんですそれでそれって
まあ本当によりしてファーな素朴
さんじゃないですよぱぷろぺらじゃなくてファンの方ですねやっぱりパティ多分人に
理解されないことだなぁと思います
いろんな人それぞれいろんな給料 c があって
なんであってそれをあのなんて言うかだ
なんか
人とで自分のこと子はもうなんか表現して伝えていければすごいいいなと考えています
はいなのでもう一度皆さんも何かこれを見て何か自分のファーを発見せですねあーは
思い出してみて何学校クリエーティブなこととか
セミたらすごい楽しいんじゃないかと思いますってひなさんも一緒につくっていきませ
んか
本日ありがとうございました